okay so yeah welcome to the tutorial
thanks very much to the organizers for
inviting me to give this tutorial kind
of excited that this room is packed I
was sure that everybody would skip my
tutorial and I come in late and then
only stay to see Lydia and Norbert and
John press go so I'm really glad
everybody actually came early to see my
stuff so I'm going to talk to you today
about characterization of quantum
devices so what motivates this
particular topic is one of the central
pillars in our field which is the fault
tolerance threshold theorem so the fault
tolerance threshold theorem is in my
opinion one of the most remarkable and
most important results of the second
half of the 20th century in in physics
period especially in quantum physics and
it basically says the following it says
that you can do an arbitrarily long
quantum computation as long as the
following two conditions are met as long
as you have errors on your gates that
are sufficiently small so I'm being
vague here for the experts the gate
error rates have to be sufficiently
small less than some epsilon which you
can quantify and the correlations
between these gate errors have to be
sufficiently weak okay and it's pretty
easy to see that these two conditions
are so you know the theorem says that
these are sufficient conditions but
there are also kind of necessary
conditions because if my gate error
rates were really strong like if
somebody comes in and smashes my
computer with 50% chance at random I'm
never going to be able to compute and if
my correlations are so strong that I
have you know with some small
probability maybe 1% a meteor hits my
quantum computer and just completely
destroys it I'm not going to be able to
do more than say a hundred gates before
my computer gets destroyed so these
conditions are also kind of necessary
and so this theorem says that you know
if we if we meet these conditions we can
build upon computer this is the
foundational result which drives you
know that that's why there's you know
100 people plus in this room right now
um so you know I said I'm being vague
about what this means so let me try to
be a little bit more precise you know
what why don't if this is all it takes
why don't we already have quantum
computers well one reason is that the
epsilon here that I haven't yet defined
is a very small number okay so I haven't
told you how I'm defining it but it's a
small number let's say it's point one
percent maybe less and it might actually
be substantially less than that it
depends on how your iron model is
defined and things like this and it also
depends on whether or not you're looking
at rigorous thresholds or numerical
simulations there's a lot of caveats
into how we compute this number we don't
really understand this number all that
well
also the overhead is really demanding so
even if you had something which was
right at this threshold or a little bit
below then the way that we prove these
theorems is we have to concatenate these
codes until we move towards a fixed
point where there's no error
you know we reach we reach an effective
state where there are no errors in the
system and the overhead to get to that
state is actually quite large so you
know we can't just sit there and build
it even if we did have these really low
error rates and finally you know I
already touched on this it's not really
clear what this number epsilon is
supposed to mean it's depending strongly
on what the error rate how we model
these errors the same is true for this
notion of weak okay so we can't just
take off the shelf components because of
these difficulties difficulties we can't
just take off the shelf components and
build a quantum computer okay and so
what we wind up doing is improving
things very slowly over a long period of
time this field is now twenty years old
plus and we've been in a sort of
engineering cycle for a long time you
know I say an engineering cycle it
involves engineering as well as
fundamental physics ideas and it's it's
not so much a cycle as it is a spiral
this particular graph is Jake and Betty
calls this the Smolin spiral but this
particular idea is ubiquitous throughout
engineering but John small and I guess
gave it these purty
labels as applied to this particular
field of characterizing quantum devices
and so the idea is that if we want to
iteratively improve our quantum devices
and in order to ratchet these error
rates down and ratchet these
correlations down lower and lower until
we can actually build functioning
quantum computers you know we need to we
need to have a few winding numbers on
this cycle so what are the points on
this the sort of weigh stations along
this spiral you can sort of start
wherever you like but the natural and
natural place to start is prioritizing
errors so you have a quantum system and
your first step is to say well what are
some dominant sources of errors maybe
it's you know and over or an under
rotation on a particular gate that you
have maybe it's straight as netic Fields
something like that maybe it's leakage
errors or photon loss okay um and now
you want to measure those things very
accurately okay because the best way to
defeat these things is to know your
enemy and then you have to fix them okay
that's it as a theorist I can just say
well yeah then you just go fix it right
but that's an enormous ly challenging
step which requires a huge amount of
ingenuity on the part of experimental
physicists as well as engineers um once
you've made some changes to your system
you have to actually verify that you did
indeed fix those errors okay so you hope
that you've improved the system you have
to verify that step by measuring those
errors and then you have to loop this
spiral oh I think I may have done it
slightly out of order doesn't really
matter oh no I did I did do it anyway
yeah sorry it goes counterclockwise okay
um so those are the sort of weigh
stations that we meet along this spiral
and so we need tools in order to help
facilitate each one of these steps and
that's what this field is about this
idea of characterizing quantum errors so
what we need is we need tools that will
help us we need to design Diagnostics so
we need to be able to diagnose and
identify dominant sources of errors we
need to be able to estimate errors so we
need tools for error metrology and they
need to be valid to very high precision
and then we need methods for so you know
we quantify these errors when we readout
we say this was the magnitude of the
error we need metrics that help us
determine whether or not that number
that we've just read out is that a small
number okay that's going to depend on
how we compare it to the fault tolerance
threshold which the threshold in turn
depends on the particular error models
so we need to understand how we're
quantifying errors and we need to be
able to understand how to quantify
things relative to fault tolerant
threshold related metrics and finally of
course the elephant in the room is
complexity we want to do all of this
with minimal resources right it's easy
to specify something that takes
exponential resources to do we want
clever techniques that save our
experimentalist colleagues time and
effort in the lab okay so that's what
this field is about these are the goals
of this field so I have an outline
normally I don't like outlines but I
think it makes sense in a talk of this
form so the first thing I'm gonna do is
so I've sort of stated what the goals of
this field are I want to now go into you
know I said resources is an important
thing so what do I even mean by
resources how are we quantifying
resources the resources that we're
trying to minimize and then what should
we even be measuring okay and there's
we'll see that there's some tension
between what we can access
experimentally and what we can analyze
theoretically that's always the case
this field is no different and then you
know the reasons for choosing the
particular measures that we choose then
there's also so then we need tools for
how to measure these particular
quantities so we're going to need so the
two main tools in our toolkit are going
to be state and process tomography and
something called randomized benchmarking
and I'm going to define them in this
first part and then in part two we're
going to go into a lot more detail so
part two is going to consist of these
are kind of pillars on which this field
rests and everything else uses these two
things as primitives and builds on it to
try to get complete characterization and
understanding of errors in quantum
devices okay so these are the primitives
that we're going to build on in part two
okay so complexity so what do I mean by
complexity there's a few different kinds
of complexity here one of them is
measurement complexity so in in some
experimental setups it's very costly for
us to change the apparatus so there may
be one particular measurement which is
given to us and it may be the case that
to change that basis or to alter the
particular measurement that we're making
in any way is an expensive resource and
so we want to charge for that by calling
it the measurement complexity so let's
say I have a single qubit and I want to
measure Sigma X Sigma Y or Sigma Z and
suppose I measure X five times in a row
and then I decide to change my up iratus
and measure Y six times and then I
measure Z seven times
the measurement complexity of that is
three just because there's three
distinct measurements that I've
performed okay so that's measurement
complexity and distinct from that is
sample complexity so in this same
example the sample complexity would be
five x measurements plus 6 y
measurements plus 7 z measurements I
don't care whether they were X or Y or Z
I'm just counting the total number of
samples so 5 plus 6 plus 7 is 18 ok so
it might be the case that repeating the
samples is a more expensive operation or
it just might be there's some there's
some relative cost between these two we
want to distinguish that measurement
complexity and sample complexity so
those are two types of complexity and
there's also of course the ubiquitous
computational complexity which again
splits into two cases there's the amount
of classical computation okay so for a
lot of the protocols that we're going to
talk about classical computation is a
bottleneck either in pre or post
processing sometimes we have adaptive
protocols where the concurrent
processing is also a bottleneck so we
want to track we want things that have a
minimal amount of classical
computational resources and importantly
there's also quantum computational
resources right so this field is kind of
predicated on we don't have we're not
assuming the existence of a perfect
functioning quantum computer anywhere so
any amount of quantum computation that
I'm charging for had better be awfully
small right I can't go and do a
polynomial sized quantum computation in
order to verify my noisy quantum device
I better be using what
say order one or maybe order login or
something like that you know short
sequences of quantum gates or else the
the point of doing the long sequence had
better be to estimate the error of that
long sequence okay so somehow we have to
be very careful about how we charge
complexity wise for the quantum
computation that we do in these schemes
okay so these are the types of resources
that we're trying to minimize so now the
most relevant scaling parameters with
which we're gonna measure that
complexity are the following so there's
always the number of qubits of course
there's D the Hilbert space dimension
okay and actually for many of the cases
that were most interested in
I'll only focus on D ok so oftentimes in
this field D is the more relevant
natural parameter so and of course if I
am talking about multiple cubed its I
can extract and just knowing D right so
usually I'm not gonna worry about it'll
be clear from context which one I'm
talking about the next important one is
epsilon which is some precision this is
some target precision I would like to be
able to give you an estimate of the
magnitude of your error in some norm I'm
gonna call that epsilon Delta is going
to be when appropriate a probability of
correctness of some kind of algorithm M
is going to be a length of some sequence
of quantum gates okay and the most
important of these parameters are going
to be D Epsilon and M we can more or
less ignore this probability of
correctness for the most part and the
reason is that most of these protocols
scale rather efficiently with this
parameter Delta usually you can amplify
it by just repeating things several
times and you only have to repeat things
log rhythmically many times in order to
get a very good success probability so
overall we tend to ignore this Delta
parameter so now I'm going to contradict
myself a bit and say that said that's a
kind of very theorists thing oh it's
just a log factor right but this fields
a lot more than many of the things that
Qi P is also data-driven right we're a
lot closer to experiment and when you're
close to experiment these constant
factors now
you can't just say up to poly log
factors well I mean you can but if you
want experimentalists to do anything
with what you've produced you're also
gonna have to meet them halfway you're
gonna have to come up with practical
heuristics that maybe don't meet all of
the conditions of your beautiful theorem
that has you know an exponential
improvement up to poly log factors you
know you better also have some practical
heuristics that make you competitive
with whatever they're currently using in
the lab okay so you know when I say
things like ignoring poly log factors
you know there's always a flip side to
that that these constant factors do
matter
practical heuristics do matter in this
field so we have to pay attention to
both of those things okay
the next thing is figures of Merit for
for quantum states this is pretty
straightforward probably everyone in
this room has read chapter 9 I think of
or is it eight of Mike and Ike so
there's two very natural measures on
states that determine distance between
two states
the first one is fidelity which is
defined in this way the one here is the
Shatan one norm I'm using the so called
squared fidelity convention there's two
conventions in the literature if you're
not aware of that so in my convention
the fidelity between a state row and a
pure States I has units of probability
okay this is a this is a function it's
bounded between 0 and 1 and it's
symmetric right so this is a very
natural thing and oftentimes I'll talk
about error rates in terms of Fidelity's
in there I just mean 1 minus the
fidelity okay
and the other natural one is the trace
distance this is also defined in terms
of the one norm and there's a there's an
inequality that relates these two in a
dimension free manner although there are
square roots that relate the two so the
infidelity here 1 minus the fidelity is
related to the trace distance using
these inequalities these are called the
folks vandegraff inequalities and so the
trace assistance also has some nice
properties
so I'll talk about these two measures at
various points throughout this talk more
interesting are measures for channels
now there are lots of different measures
for channels but really I'm only going
to talk about two the two most important
ones are what's called the average error
rate which is defined as follows so here
I've written the definition only in
terms of where one of the two gates is a
unitary gate so you could think of that
that's like the target gate I want to
compare a noisy implementation of some
unitary u so I have a noisy
implementation e of a unitary gate you
and I want to compare these two and I
want to compare them with this function
called the average error rate and this
is the definition assuming one of the
two channels is unitary which is the
only case that we're gonna use in this
talk so this is a function that's
bounded not between zero and one but
between zero and D over D plus one where
D is the dimension of the Hilbert space
this was not my choice this was defined
before I came along and now we're stuck
with it because it's in the literature
and all the experimentalists always
quote this number sorry about that it's
symmetric in two in both arguments it
has some other nice properties if you
are familiar with something called the
process fidelity it's related by this
equation one minus the rescaled version
so the process fidelity does go between
zero and one so this average error rate
if you rescale it properly and you take
one minus that it becomes the process
fidelity okay this is importantly this
is not a norm so one mutton you know you
might think this thing is enormous not a
norm it does not obey the triangle
inequality okay and that'll be important
later on you know it has a sort of
obvious physical interpretation is just
the average error if I if I prepare a
state's I and I evolve it perfectly
under you or perfectly under this
channel e sorry I prepare the states I
chosen uniformly at random and then I do
a noisy evolution E and then I do a
perfect inverse evolution did I get back
to where I started what's the
probability if I then measures in the
basis sy
- I measure that to outcome POV n what's
the probability I get yes I'm back in
the state I started okay I know I that
overall states that's the interpretation
of this number okay so this quantity R
it will be convenient so I mentioned
that we have these scaling parameters
it's important to discuss complexity in
terms of DM sequence length and
dimension D and precision epsilon it
will also be convenient to use R itself
as one of those scaling parameters
because we'll find if you define your
protocols in certain ways you can
actually do better for things like it
turns out the small R regime is
computationally very challenging so we
want to actually have our estimates of
complexity reflect the true value of R
that we're trying to estimate okay so
I'm gonna add this parameter R to our
list of scaling parameters that are
relevant for determining complexity okay
the other relevant figure of Merit for
channels is a so called diamond distance
mathematicians will know this as the
completely bounded norm or CB norm so it
has this kind of funny-looking
definition with an optimization here
over all possible states so I take two
different channels that I'm trying to
compare epsilon is noisy F is some ideal
channel which we think of as maybe being
a unitary Channel and now I tensor on an
identity system okay this allows me to
do some kind of entangled strategy right
it might be that so this is a
distinguishability measure and by ten
suring on additional degrees of freedom
i can do something like think of a an
interference experiment right if I have
a second arm in an interferometer I can
get more information about some system
right so this is sort of the kind of
experiments that I'm allowing that's the
intuition at least so this quantity is
then the one norm maximized over all
possible input States okay it turns out
this is indeed a norm it's bounded
between zero and one there is an
inequality that relates D to R but it's
a very weak dependence okay
so this is a kind of analog of the folks
Van de Graaff inequality I should say
that we don't know that this upper bound
is saturated
we know that the scalings in terms of D
and in terms of square root of R it's
possible to saturate both of those
scalings independently but it might be
that there exists a tighter bound of the
form order D plus root R or something
like that but as far as but but the
known relationships that constrain D in
terms of r are rather weak okay and
we'll get back to that in a bit so there
are some relationships between these
measures but there's quite a lot of
wiggle room especially when R is very
small or when the dimension is large
this thing is a true norm it obeys the
triangle inequality and it has an
operational interpretation as the
maximum bias if you give me a single
shot measurement and I'm trying to
distinguish in one try with the best
possible bias did you hand me a black
box with the channel or with the channel
F this is the maximum bias with which I
can succeed at that task okay so okay
why these particular figures of Merit
okay so first question why do people
care about this distance D diamond norm
the main reason is it obeys two very
important inequalities
well equality one is an inequality one
is an equality the first is called
chaining which says the following if I
compose a sequence of two channels so I
want to do too noisy channels that you
want an e2 and I want to compare it to a
sequence of two ideal channels F 1 and F
2 then this is bounded by f1 the diamond
distance between f1 and E 1 plus the
diamond distance between F 2 and e 2
okay so this says that arrows grow at
most linearly okay so like I said the
average error rate does not obey this
okay errors can grow super linearly if
I'm measuring them with respect to the
average error rate our diamond norm does
not have that property at obeys this
chaining inequality it also has this
stability property because we tensor don
and n sella in part of the definition
it's it's stable under tensor and even
more in Seles
you know add another and Sylla well I
already added that so we're done so this
means that whatever is happening you
know on Jupiter doesn't actually affect
the value of this norm okay um so these
are really convenient properties if you
want to use this to prove a theorem
about fault tolerance and theorists
really like this for that reason it also
has a nice characterization in terms of
semi definite programs which means using
semi definite duality we can get really
good bounds on calculating this for
specific channels okay so that's very
useful if you're a theorist it's not so
useful if you're an experimentalist
because it's very hard to measure D
directly or you would have to do some
kind of optimization over all possible
states but what people can do in the lab
is estimate are efficiently okay and
what we'll see later on in this talk is
this randomized benchmarking this
quantity are actually gives us a method
to do it the basic idea is because this
is has this interpretation as a random
procedure right an averaged procedure I
can I can just do a Monte Carlo type
estimation to learn the value of R okay
so experimentalists love are the average
error rate because they can measure in
okay that's a pretty important feature
okay so now we've we've just discussed
what it means to be what what complexity
is how we're gonna quantify it why we've
chosen the things to choose I should say
just packing up for a second there's
lots of other sensible things that you
could use to measure distance I'm not
gonna talk about any of them simply
because I don't have time okay those
these are the two most important ones
okay so there are a lot of strategies
for characterizing noise in quantum
devices and you can sort of string them
all out on a line which has two sides to
it the first is on the on the left side
we see tools and techniques I haven't
defined any of these yet but we'll get
to it on the left side we have
techniques that have very low complexity
they're going to be pretty efficient
okay but they are also going to give us
less information we hope that it's
relevant information but comparatively a
small amount of information and over
here at the other end
we have things that take an enormous
amount of complexity exponential scaling
but they'll give us in principle
complete information about a process
okay
and so the two pillars that I talked
about earlier randomized benchmarking
and full tomography or processed
tomography they sit on either end and
they sort of pin down the boundaries of
this line and then everything else that
we do tries to interpolate the
advantages of full information but
without the high complexity from the
tomography side and the low complexity
but less information we try to gain a
little bit more information while
keeping low complexity over here from
the randomized benchmarking side okay so
the whole field can be seen as trying to
fill in the gaps in this line to gain
the advantages that we have on either
side okay so like I said the two pillars
of this field benchmarking in tomography
that's what I'll talk about for the
remainder of part 1 of this talk so
before talking about tomography I'm just
going to use a little bit of notation
which many of you have probably seen
before and you'll see it a lot tomorrow
during Norbert Shooks tutorial which is
this diagrammatic notation for
describing linear algebra ok so if I
have a multi linear tensor I can
describe that tensor by an object just a
like a little diagram like a ball with a
label and some legs hanging off of it an
unpaired leg is an open tensor index
okay so this these two things are
equivalent in this notation and if I
draw a closed leg between two objects
that's equivalent to just summing over a
shared index there so I can only match
two legs if they have the same type that
is if as Beca spaces they have the same
dimension and then this is a shorthand
for just summing over those interior
legs okay and if one of these legs has a
dimension which is composite a composite
number
I can always Pat it to be like a power
of two or something I can split that leg
by just taking that basis and writing it
out bitwise okay so I can take
I can take these legs in general and I
can split them up into lots of smaller
legs or I can conversely I can group
them together into one big sort of macro
leg that's just an isomorphism between
those vector spaces okay so in this
notation you know an inner product just
looks like this right I take two vectors
and I can track them a matrix on vector
multiply looks like this matrix matrix
multiplication looks like this and a
loop like this is just a trace okay so
probably you've all seen this before
it's a very natural notation but I just
want to make sure I'm not drawing
pictures that confuse people later on
okay so what is quantum state tomography
quantum state tomography is just I
prepare some unknown state row in a lab
okay
and I'm I prepared I'm able to prepare
this many times I push a button the
state row pops out and then I measure it
okay so this is a vector this is a dual
vector so this is an inner product okay
I'm measuring some POV M that has POV M
effects E and these experiments that I'm
going to do define some probability
distribution from the born rule P of
this effect the probability of this of
seeing outcome e given this particular
state Rho now I'm going to sample this
many many times to get an estimate of
this probability distribution okay so we
can formalize this with the notion of a
sampling operator so the sampling
operator is just a linear map that takes
hermitian D by D density operators or
sorry permission D by D matrices Maps
them to real numbers of some length so K
is going to be the number of distinct
outcomes that I have for this
probability distribution and so a of
some test input row the J element is
just exactly the born rule probability
of seeing that particular P of yem
effect a sub J so it's Tracy sub J of
Rho okay so this is the sampling
operator it's just the linear map that
takes me from states two probabilities
that's all it is so the states and the
data that I'm going to get out are
linearly related great so
there's one thing we know how to do its
linear algebra arguably that's the only
thing we know how to do okay so so in
practice of course there's noise right
we're doing a sampling procedure in a
lab there's gonna be some noise so let's
just suppose for the sake of argument
that this noise can be modeled as some
Gaussian noise so the data that I
collect doesn't look like a of Rho it's
not the exact probability distribution
but rather let's suppose a simple noise
model where I just add a vector of iid
Gaussian random variables to this okay
this isn't a particularly realistic
noise model especially for states that
are very close to pure States and things
like this but it's going to illustrate
the point that I'm trying to make so now
we have these data Y vector of list of
estimates of this probability
distribution and I just said it's what
it's linearly related to the input great
so we're done we know how to solve this
problem this is the least squares
problem and we've solved back by I can
gauss in like a long time ago and it has
a closed form solution so i can
construct an estimate rho hat by just
taking this inverse a transpose a taking
the inverse times a transpose acting on
y this is the least squares solution and
it has an optimality property it's
what's called the minimum variance
unbiased estimator okay so this is in
fact even for a certain sense an optimal
solution okay so we're done right well
not really because there's all sorts of
caveats here right just like statistics
didn't end
back when Gauss and came up with this
tomography doesn't end with this
observation that it's linear so in
practice there's always noise right even
if I prepared the same state every time
there's going to be some noise channel
that gets applied and moreover these
measurements here are not ever perfect
okay so the noise means we can only
reconstruct not the original state but
noise plus the state
okay we're always going to conflate the
noise sources with the state that we're
trying to reconstruct people call this
and errors which was a very clever name
that J Gambetta came up with so state
preparation and measurement errors
nobody likes spam so one of the major
problems with just immediately using
tomography is that the state preparation
and measurement errors produce a noise
floor below which you cannot get an
accurate estimation of the error rate in
preparing this state the same is true
for quantum gates as well if we're doing
process tomography um also we're
assuming that the noise is iid or
equivalently if you're a Bayesian
exchangeable prior so we're not in this
formalism at least as I've laid it out
so far
drift and time dependence is not
tolerated also it's extremely resource
intensive so it's going to be
exponential in the size of this state so
you know complexity is a key bottleneck
in doing this the reconstructed state at
least for this particular linear
inversion estimator there are other more
clever estimators but I won't really
have time to talk about much except in
passing the reconstructed state or
channel might not even be a positive
operator or in the case of channels a CP
map completely positive map also the
last challenge is there are probably
other challenges these are certainly
some of the most important quantifying
the uncertainty of the estimate is
actually pretty challenging so it's even
if you can get a point estimate for the
reconstructed state getting an error
region and quantifying that error region
is hard because part of the region is
it's such a high dimensional space like
if you're talking about reconstructing
at ophélie gate an approximation of some
hopefully gate that you're doing in the
lab you know this is a really big object
this is a map from an eighth dimensional
space to an eighth dimensional space so
it's like a 64 by 64 matrix as a super
operator so it's a very high dimensional
space okay nonetheless experimentalists
have had some success in doing this the
most impressive effort using what I
would call without using any fancier
tricks which we'll get to in part two
is this paper from 2005 by Hefner at all
which is an experiment that was done in
the block group at Innsbruck it's an ion
trap experiment where they created a W
state the W state recall is the if I
have an N qubit W state it's just a
superposition of all strings with
Hamming weight one okay so it's a
uniform superposition of all the strings
of Hamming weight one and so if you plot
the coefficients of the density operator
you get some funny plot that looks like
this and they actually measured they did
full tomography on eight qubits it took
them something like two weeks of
computation to produce an estimate
together with some error bars so it was
extremely resource intensive in order to
do this they didn't use a linear
inversion estimate they use the other
sort of most popular estimator that
people use which guarantees that the
output state is positive semi-definite
is something called maximum likelihood
estimation and you know that's the other
most popular estimator that people use
when they're doing state tomography okay
so the complexity is really high but if
you're a world-leading group you can do
it for for you know a sizable number of
qubits right okay so more on tomography
and practice I said you know we have
theorems about these things there's also
the importance of practical heuristics
so there are software packages that
people have written that help you do
tomography so if you're interested in
analyzing people's actual data you
should look into some of these one is by
Feist and Renner it's called tomography
if they were clever they would have
dropped the e and made it an app so it's
like cool so they use like a metropolis
Hastings style resampler to start with a
Bayesian error region and then they
resample it to get conference confidence
regions on top of that and the other one
is Q infer which actually has some other
broader uses which I'll talk about more
later by grenade at all it uses a part
of
filtering to approximate posterior
distributions it gives you Bayesian
credible regions so these are both
open-source software implementations if
somebody says to you oh we have all this
data will you analyze it you don't have
to start from scratch there are tools
that are that are being developed that
are available they're open source you
can use those ok so that's one of the
two pillars that we have over here the
other main pillar that we're gonna build
on is randomized benchmarking so by
contrast so tomography was limited by
two main factors the first was this idea
of spam errors the state preparation and
measurement errors which create this
noise floor below which we can't get an
accurate estimate and the second one
that limits us is the very high
complexity of doing these
implementations so our be randomized
benchmarking is an attempt to avoid two
of these difficulties and the cost the
price that we're gonna pay is that we're
not going to get full complete
information we're just going to get out
a single parameter okay but that's a
starting point and as I said you know
we're gonna grow we're gonna build on
this so right it's a method to extract
less information but it a lot lower
complexity and in a more robust way ok
so what's the main idea the main idea is
to amplify errors on our gates by doing
long sequences and this will also D
couple the errors from state preparation
and measurement by pushing them to the
ends of a very long sequence and then
we're gonna try to figure out what those
error rates are on the individual gates
at least in some average suitably
average sense okay so we start by
preparing a state row this is another
tensor Network diagram so this is an
inner product right this is a product of
matrices followed by a you know isn't it
this is a born rule in our product
that's what that diagram means so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna choose a
random set s of Clifford gates of length
M okay with the caveat that so the
sequence itself is going to be length n
plus 1 and the last gate is going to be
the product of all the previous gates
inverse ok so I can compile that
efficiently by using the goddess makino
theorem right I can just multiply all
those Clifford gates on my
Skol computer get a new clifford gate
and invert that and then write that as
some small compiled Clifford gate right
here so then the product of all of these
gates is the identity okay so that means
if I had a perfect state Rho let's say
the zero state and a perfect pov em in
the computational basis and all these
gates were ideal I would just always see
one I would get one every time I did
this experiment for every sequence
length M okay so I'm gonna do this for a
random choice of there's 24 Clifford
gates on a single qubit I'm gonna sample
from all 24 to the M Clifford's
uniformly okay so I'm picking these
sequences uniformly at random for each
sequence and for various sequence
lengths M I'm gonna run this experiment
okay but they're these gates are now
noisy the state preparations and
measurements are also noisy that means
I'm not gonna always get back to where I
started and in fact I expect my errors
to slowly build up over time okay so I'm
gonna do this experiment I'm gonna make
a measurement I'm gonna do this for lots
of different sequences and every time I
make one of these measurements I'm gonna
record the outcome I'm gonna potentially
I'm gonna repeat this many times not
just for many sequences but potentially
many times for the same sequence
although that is in some sense optional
which I'll talk about in a minute so I'm
gonna repeat this experiment many many
times I'm gonna collect a whole bunch of
data and I'm gonna see a decay as I grow
the sequence length M it's gonna tell me
how my errors are building up and adding
up okay so if I do that experiment I get
something that looks like this okay so
here each one of these dots represents a
point estimate of the particular
fidelity of a specific noisy sequence
okay so this is you know sequence number
3802 this is some other sequence and so
on and I've sampled them many times so
I've estimated the probability of
success for those individual sequences
so now what I can do is I can
additionally average out the inter
sequence variants alright so there's two
types of variants it's important that we
keep the keep track of those
there's the variance just from the
quantum noise of Sam
something that's not you know in the
basis in which I'm trying to measure and
then there's the noise the variance
between the different sequences okay so
let's let's now average out the
individual sequences the between
sequence variants and I get something
that looks like this okay
so it turns out this thing is we're
gonna prove in a minute it's an
exponential decay or a shifted
exponential decay so it has some decay
curve that looks like this where decay
parameter is related to the average
error rate which I'll derive in a minute
this is the so-called zeroth order model
and we've made some assumptions here
about the noise we're still assuming
things like time and gate independence
I'll get to that later on but you know
if those assumptions are all met you get
a really beautiful decay curve in the
slope of this decay curve is telling us
about the growth of our errors over time
we're gonna now prove that this relates
back to this average error rate okay so
what's the proof of that it's a really
simple and beautiful proof so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to factor each of
these gates
I had the expression on the last slide
I'm gonna factor every physical gate
into an ideal unitary times some noise
lambda okay so lambda is now a noise
channel and for every I'm going to
assume like I said gate independence so
regardless of which Clifford I'm trying
to do for the sake of simplicity I get
the same noise every time alright now I
can now write a noisy sequence like this
and now I've absorbed some of the noise
into the boundary conditions okay I'm
gonna be a little bit sloppy about how I
handle the boundaries you can work
through the proof yourself and see how
that works but yeah you can handle the
boundaries so now I'm gonna go in and
I'm gonna insert the identity in a bunch
of different places throughout this
chain so here I'm gonna insert c1 c1
inverse and then I'm gonna put C 2 C 2 C
2 inverse C 2 here and so on down the
chain okay so now when I do that it
factorizes
it looks like this and now I've just
sort of clustered them in a suggestive
way right each of these individual gates
is still a random unitary so I can I can
just you know rewrite the sum or rewrite
the I can rewrite all of these gates in
terms of different also equally random
unitary is just by rotating the Clifford
group and now what I'm interested in is
the average right so when we take this
data we average over sequences right so
that means we get this actual
probability or at least an estimate of
it and then i additionally average over
the sequences that's this expectation
value out here on the edge so when I do
this expectation each one of these
things is an independent degree of
freedom okay so by independence the
expected value of the product is just
the product of the expected values I
just pull in a different expected value
for each one of these each one of these
expected values is the same answer okay
so I only have to analyze the expected
value of this one channel and then I'm
gonna have to power it up many times
okay so if I average this over the
entire Clifford group I get this I get
this group average right so this
property this has the property that it's
it's a group invariant right so we can
use sure's lemma to say you know
whatever's in here has to commute
through okay so that means I can use
some representation theory and a little
bit of linear algebra to conclude
exactly what this operator this is it
this is a channel right this is a super
operator I can write exactly what this
channel is it turns out it's a
depolarizing channel if I use the
Clifford group more generally I didn't
have to use the Clifford group the only
property that I'm using when I when I
make this assertion is oh yeah I should
say I'm using this to design property
which says this group average is in fact
equal to the ha ravage over the entire
unitary group okay so I didn't have to
use the Clifford group I could use any
unitary to design if you don't know what
a unitary to design is it's the groups
that have this property
okay and so what that means is I'm left
with just some average Channel okay the
unitarily invariant average right so the
Clifford average gives me the unitary
average of the full unitary group and
this average noise now splits it just
has two pieces one piece is the identity
Channel and the other piece is the
completely depolarizing channel and
they're weighted in some way okay and
those two weights I'm gonna call them P
and 1 minus P that's like a depolarizing
probability for this depolarizing
channel okay so now I've this the
average of this now over all sequences
reduces to this right it's just some
noisy preparation right weight which I'm
just gonna you know call that Rho some
noisy measurement E and then a
depolarizing channel raised to some
power M so when I do that oh oh I can I
can solve for the value of this
depolarizing channel by the way P in
terms of that har integral that I showed
you before that defined the average
error rate R okay and what I find is
that this probability P is related to
the average error rate by the following
formula okay so this thing is a little
bit less than 1
think of R as being a very small number
it's a very small error rate and so this
P is some number a little bit less than
1 which is decaying very very slowly if
I fit this on a log plot you see now I
can extract from that slope I can
exactly extract the value of R from this
experiment so the fit gives us a
straightforward way to estimate this
average error rate so what have we
actually determined in a benchmarking
experiment we've determined this is
important the average error of an
average Clifford gate assuming well
assuming what there's a list of
assumptions just like in tomography
those assumptions are at least gate
independence okay
so in order for me to write in order for
me to do
this equals this har a ver äj-- each of
these channels lambda has to be
independent of J if I were to put a
little index J on each of those lambdas
to account for gate dependent noise I
could no longer write it as sum averaged
noise channel okay so I'm assuming gate
dependence
sorry gate independence in this
derivation I'm also assuming Markovian
ID of the noise that there exists a CP
TP map a completely positive and trace
preserving map that acts on the system
of interest at each of these time steps
okay and then it's time independent it's
not just Markovian it's also a time
independent Markov process and so I'm
not accounting for any drift right if
there is some drift in how my noise
behaves as a function of time you know
then I'm gonna see the average over that
drift if I just do this experiment right
and I'm also using this to design
property okay so if I were to do this
instead of averaging over the Clifford
group if I averaged over let's say the
poly group which is only a unitary one
design okay it no longer satisfies this
very nice property it's not equal to
this the average over the poly operators
is not equal to the higher average and
I'll pick up a whole bunch of extra
terms here I'll pick up something like 4
to the or I'll pick up like d squared
different terms for a D dimensional
system okay so I'll have to fit like a
multi Multi exponential decay in that
case there will be lots of different
decay parameters so the beauty of the to
design thing is it reduces the
complexity of fitting to just one
parameter okay so these are all the
assumptions that have gone into this
right and if these assumptions are
respected then I get the average error
of the average Clifford gate in my
ensemble okay right so what does this
look like in practice so right so one of
the questions you can ask is about the
complexity and we're going to talk a
little bit more about this either now or
possibly in part two so
we want to understand sort of how many
sequences I need and how many times I
have to repeat each of those sequences
if I'm working in that limit in order to
get an estimate that's accurate to some
very small number so here is an
experiment by the nist group where they
did what does it say they get an average
error rate of on the order of like 10 to
the minus 4 or 5 I left it out of my
presenter notes by mistake Thanks
and here is another value sorry another
experiment where they get and they
estimate an error rate of something like
1 part in 10 to the 6 but you know
eyeball this and decide for yourself are
they taking enough data here to justify
this sort of fit line is this like a
good is this really encompassing the
average error rate or you know it is the
average a good description of the errors
in this particular system it depends on
a lot of factors so also there's
benchmarking in practice so I mentioned
software implementations for tomography
so for for benchmarking there are at
least three that I know about the first
one is you can sort of do it yourself
just in MATLAB where the fit parameter
the way you just you find these fit
parameters is the N Lin fit or ker fit
inside PI these have some problems that
I don't entirely understand my postdoc
understands them much better than I do
because he is really good at programming
stuff and you get unphysical parameters
it sort of over optimizes things and
gives you back on physical parameters
for the spam so that makes it a little
bit hard to trust some of these
estimates I mean I think that you know
they look decent when you look at them I
don't know that there is any major
mistakes anywhere in the literature but
you know it does give you some
hesitation in using some of these
[Music]
fitting functions there's also cue infer
which I mentioned previously so this
provides you know not just a point
estimate it also comes free with error
bars so one of the nice things about
this which I'll talk about in a little
bit is that the error bars sort of come
for free if you work in this limit where
you re sample sequences every time and
then the last one that'll give you that
sort of open source off-the-shelf RB
software is what's called pigsty it
actually comes up with RB estimates as a
special case of a more complicated
procedure called Gateshead tomography
which I'll talk about at the end of Part
two
so I'm actually done with part one I was
told ten minutes for questions so so
I'll wrap up part one now and and pause
and ask for any questions thank you
stoop so questions yeah pull in the
running Hey
so you've shown some experimental data
with very large error bars or these
statistical or intrinsic because if
they're intrinsic it sort of means that
the the noise is not in the yeah so with
this one
I think I mean the claim in the paper
it's hard to know right
their data isn't published as far as I
know I mean I looked at the yeah the the
I I haven't seen the data I think I
remember checking in the archive post
and didn't see their data but if I
remember correctly the claim is that
these are statistical errors here but
they very well might be systematic
errors right so you know one of the
things I'll touch on in part two is how
do we distinguish systematic from
statistical errors that's an important
direction of current research so yeah
it's it's unknown from the data that was
presented in this paper as far as I know
okay more questions okay so so you said
in your proof for this fidelity fit that
if you use a one design then it breaks
the proof right
yes um but if I use a higher design like
a three design or higher can I get more
than just the average deli or is there
something else well yeah so the limit
you would just do a uniform horror
random unitary right yeah I thought a
little bit about this three designs are
funny objects you mentioned three
designs so it's a bit of an aside I
don't really know of any uses of a three
design it seems like only the even
numbers so there's one and then one is
sort of special because it's also a
basis so it's kind of an interesting
object in itself but I don't know of any
uses for a three or a five design if you
had a four design you could say
something very concrete about the
variance of this procedure so what I'll
talk about in part two actually is we've
bounded the variance without using the
fact that it's a four design because the
Clifford group is not before design
unfortunately but if you had something
like a four design you could in
principle get a simple proof or a simple
understanding of the variance of an RV
estimate variance over sequences and
that would be useful thank you
quite you should picture all right where
are you sure they're a true extreme we
have liked it randomized benchmarking
and those so the photo tomography can
you just explain a little bit about a
sensor in the middle sorry can you oh
all of part two is gonna be well do I
start my slides with that hold on no
yeah all of part two is filling in the
middle did me the hard yeah so the whole
next hour is filling in the middle yeah
fix the boundaries first and then we're
gonna fill in the bulk in the random
light bench amake if the assumption of
timing independence is correct
do I really need to increase the M it's
a number of Clifford okay's to estimate
because I think if I choose a mix yeah
just pick em to be as large as you want
and so by picking lots of different
values of M you're giving yourself an
independent test for all those different
choices right so I mean yeah what you
say is completely correct if the
assumption is satisfied you don't need
to do it for lots of different choices
of M you just pick the largest M that
you want just do it for there and you're
done but by doing it and then doing the
fit you know you've done it you've done
a non-trivial check I love that
assumption right which is why when you
sort of look at this you're like well
was there some drift here you know I
don't know not not to pick on them too
much like I think it's probably it's
still an impressive experiment but yeah
okay I have time for one or two more
questions anymore okay just to ask a
question do you want to say anything
more about other measures you talked
about diamond yes ah yeah okay yeah yeah
you want me to talk about sandwich
trendy entropies right I mean okay yeah
there's lots of other measures you could
think about like relative entropy for
example I mean that one's a little bit
pathological though because if your
right arms no no people don't use it
people don't use it because it has
certain pathologies I mean I think that
I think that the only other so for
channels at least the average error rate
is significant precisely because people
can measure it quite easily if you gave
me another measure wherein you could
prove fault tolerant threshold theorems
okay so the diamond distance is one such
measure where I can go and I can just
prove a threshold if you've had another
measure the diamond distance is not
special right if you if you have
something else that had sort of nice
theoretical properties and you could go
in and you could say yeah all right it
says something non-trivial about
composability about you know because
everything that I'm talking about is
characterizing individual gates but
really we're characterizing these things
as part of larger circuits all right so
we need to understand how these things
compose and we're trying to ultimately
at the end of the day talk about the
threshold okay so if you have some
measure that you can connect back to a
threshold by any means and it has some
nice theoretical properties that let you
do that we're interested if then also
becomes relevant how do you measure it
experimentally or if you can't figure
out how to measure it experimentally how
do you take things that you can measure
and correlate them with this new measure
okay so there's no particular reason for
diamond distance other than it's the
best thing that we got it's better it's
like democracy it's better than
everything it's the worst except for
everything else channel bureaus distance
satisfies this
yes that's true okay that involves
taking a square root it involves taking
a square root so I'll touch on this next
but this square root that allows you to
convert between average error rate and
diamond distance you can do that but
then you can do that you can you can use
borough as distance yes that's perfectly
reasonable it doesn't give you any
significant advantage as far as I know
yeah it's a good point thank you Stu
fun stirring questions so now we have
half an hour coffee break you back at
11:00 there's coffee and bagels
available and please enjoy thank you